pues acabamos las noticias y vamos ya
con nuestro repaso de la salud este
viernes También con Natalia plazas
Natalia bienvenida a este estudio Buenos
días Rodrigo bienvenido buenas días
también vamos a arrancar en Estados
Unidos donde se lleva a cabo una batalla
legal en torno a la píldora abortiva
mifepristona que ha vuelto a poner en el
centro del debate Los derechos
reproductivos de las mujeres en ese país
si Rodrigo es una batalla legal como
bien dices que se da Después de que un
juez Federal en Texas prohibiera la
distribución de uno de los fármacos más
utilizados para lo para posibilitar
abortos en el país el fallo fue anulado
parcialmente por una corte de
apelaciones y el gobierno dijo que
buscará la forma de hacer que este
medicamento puedas este accesible en
todo el país estamos hablando
concretamente Rodrigo de la píldora
abortiva mifepristona y vamos a
aprovechar este espacio de salida de
salud para explicar qué es y cómo
funciona esta píldora la es una pastilla
que se administra en conjunto con otro
fármaco que es el misoprostol primero se
administra la
mifepristona que trabaja concretamente
bloqueando una hormona que se llama la
progesterona la progesterona es la
hormona que permite que los embarazos
puedan seguir desarrollándose en El Paso
seguidamente después de esta
administración se administra el
misoprostol que es genera este este
medicamento este segundo paso genera
contracciones en el útero provocando que
el útero el útero se vacíe y genera
físicamente lo que es el aborto
actualmente estas dos pastillas
representan más de la mitad de los
abortos en el país Rodrigo bueno Y es
que quienes quieren prohibir este
tratamiento dicen aseguran que no es
segura para las mujeres esto Pese a que
se lleva usando durante más de 20 años
en Estados Unidos sí sus detractores
buscan que la agencia encargada de
regular los medicamentos en el país la
fda anule una aprobación que le dio como
dices hace 23 años concretamente en el
año 2000 consideran que su uso pone en
peligro tanto a mujeres como
adolescentes porque consideran que se
administra con poca supervisión médica
sin embargo las cifras que justamente ha
recogido la fda durante estos 23 años
señalan que realmente el fármaco es
bastante seguro en estos años unos
3,7 millones de pacientes han utilizado
han recurrido a la mifepristona para
practicarse un aborto lo que ha podido
determinar la fda es que se han
detectado que el medicamento puede
llegar a causar hasta cinco muertes por
cada millón de usuarios esto podemos
decir Rodrigo que es relativamente poco
si lo comparamos por ejemplo con otros
fármacos como la penicilina que también
es un fármaco administrado digamos muy
entre los sistemas de salud y la
penicilina puede llegar a causar hasta
20 muertes por cada millón de habitantes
si hablamos de efectividad el
tratamiento conjunto de ambos fármacos
puede tener un efecto de Hasta el 95% de
acuerdo a estudios nacionales esto
quiere decir que
un 95% de los abortos se acaban
realizando de manera eficaz en medio de
la discusión en la jefa de la unidad
para prevenir abortos inseguros de la
Organización Mundial de la Salud reiteró
nuevamente su apoyo a este medicamento y
dijo que incluso hay países que están
buscando hacer más accesible hacerlo más
accesible para la población veamos
la mifepristona y el misoprostol son
seguros y efectivos 8 países bangladesh
Liberia malawi nepal Nigeria Ruanda
Sierra Leona y Sudáfrica evaluaron cómo
hacerlos más accesibles
bueno con todos estos datos que nos
señalas parece que la inseguridad es
solo una excusa para imponer una agenda
política en Estados Unidos contra los
derechos abortivos de las mujeres vamos
a seguir porque qué podría cambiar en
torno al uso de este medicamento en
medio de la batalla legal que se está
llevando a cabo bueno Rodrigo como
decíamos el medicamento Hasta ahora ha
estado ampliamente disponible e incluso
hasta las 10 semanas de embarazo durante
la pandemia también se buscó que pudiera
estar disponible también por correo que
algunas farmacias autorizadas
certificadas pudieran distribuirlo por
correo y esto concretamente en enero la
fda buscó que esto fuera ya permanente
sin embargo el juez Texano prohibió su
distribución mientras también un grupo
de activistas antiaborto están
interponiendo una demanda para como
decíamos pedir que la fda finalmente
retire la aprobación de este medicamento
hasta el momento un tribunal de
apelaciones lo anuló este fallo del juez
pero mantuvo algunos de sus mandatos
entre estos mandatos está que se reduce
el uso del medicamento de 10 a 7 semanas
y que no pueda ser
suministrado por forma mediante el
correo postal sino que tenga que ser
recetado en una consulta presencial con
un médico por el movimiento como se ha
visto en los últimos días el gobierno ha
reiterado en varias ocasiones que pedirá
la Corte Suprema que el medicamento
vuelva a estar disponible para toda la
población bien Natalia vamos ahora a
ampliar el foco a la situación general
del aborto en Estados Unidos porque esta
decisión llega también después de que
pasado junio la Corte Suprema anulara el
histórico fallo Rover versus weight que
garantizaba el derecho al aborto a nivel
Federal sí Rodrigo como como bien dices
lo garantizaba y hacía del aborto un
derecho constitucional para toda la
población
tras su revocación cada estado ha podido
regular el aborto de acuerdo a las
digamos las tendencias políticas dentro
de cada estado en los últimos meses
justamente varios estados han prohibido
el aborto con causales prácticamente
completas en 13 estados completamente
está vigente en este momento entre ellos
Texas
wisconsil O Oklahoma y también cabe
Resaltar que por ejemplo en Georgia se
ha impuesto también el aborto la
prohibición al aborto hasta las seis
semanas que es un momento en el que
muchas personas muchas mujeres todavía
no se han dado cuenta de que están
embarazadas para algunos el envío por
ejemplo del medicamento por correo
suponía un alivio a todas estas
restricciones que se han ido imponiendo
en los últimos meses en varios estados
del país Y es que recordemos también que
los abortos clandestinos que se
practican normalmente cuando es ilegal
en un país abortar suelen ser una de las
principales causas de mortalidad materna
a nivel mundial causan millones de
muertes cada año médicos en fronteras y
otras organizaciones que trabajan
anualmente con mujeres que se practican
abortos clandestinos han recordado que
generalmente cuando una mujer o una niña
están determinadas a finalizar con sus
embarazos
no les no hay nada que les impida
hacerlo independientemente de la
seguridad o de la legalidad del
procedimiento en sus países y entonces
sí que hay peligro de muerte Natalia
poco que Añadir hasta Tan completa
Crónica de salud de hoy Muchas gracias
por este repaso nos vemos la semana que
viene Gracias Rodrigo